let's get back to the central matter
here this is one thing when we're
dealing with the civilian population I
mean it's
jaw dropping and uh I struggle to find
words to uh
to even encapsulate how terrifying it is
to watch this thing not even interested
in vaccinating as many people who as
will accept it but strong arming people
into it but this becomes so much more
dangerous when it's the military to whom
we are doing this because the role the
military plays in preserving this system
is obviously you know literally at the
front line so
um and the fact that the mandates have
held on more tenaciously in that context
presumably that's because
the chain of command uh already has a
leg up on telling members of the
military what to do right and the
circumstances in which a member of the
military is Justified in refusing uh an
order are you know those are extreme
circumstances and so I mean a
I do see a kind of turning of the tables
here right we in the civilian population
cannot leave our military behind if we
have successfully fended off these
mandates because they were medically
absurd to begin with
um and extremely dangerous the younger
you were the more dangerous they were
this is about the future of that
civilian population for us now to walk
away from that issue while the military
is still exposed to this danger is not
only foolish from the point of view of
our long-term well-being in the civilian
population but it's it's
um uh it's it's a betrayal of the
service that the military provides for
the nation so
can we talk about what that's like to be
um
forgotten to have your mandates persist
after the civilian population has more
or less escaped its
yeah Brett this has been incredibly
troubling I think one of the challenges
that I saw was the Secretary of Defense
mandated the covid-19 vaccine in August
of 2021 at that point after over a year
and a half of living with covid we'd
lost 28 military service members
now obviously any loss of life is you
know terrible thing but that number is
far eclipsed by suicides motorcycle
accidents you know alcohol-related
incidents
after implementing the Mandate by
October late October that number had
more than doubled and we'd gone to 70
military deaths that were you know
labeled due to covid and those are the
dod Zone the department of defense's own
numbers
at that point it shocked me that
um considering there was no parallel in
the civilian population the Department
of Defense didn't feel a need to stop
and reassess the order that they had put
out
having witnessed such an incredible loss
of life
um
I don't understand what's going on and
to your point with you know capture or
whatever is happening clearly clearly
things are not where they need to be one
of the things that the military is known
for and as a prior Aviator one of the
things we always do after every mission
is to debrief and so you know you go you
prep for a mission you fly your mission
hopefully you get the bad guys and then
you come back and you talk about it and
you say hey guys how can we do this
better in the future and we haven't
seemed to do that at all with any of
these policies which is just not aligned
with military culture and has been
really disturbing you know it's shocking
frankly
yeah and look I I again I know that we
have to be very careful about
what hypotheses we entertain here but
this is another data point
the idea that you would not reflect on
the policy and figure out what worked
and what didn't and what was its effect
on our Readiness and how can we fix it
exactly that is also consistent with you
know I will try to find some alternative
to enemy action but it is beyond
incompetent right an incompetent entity
might review what happened incompetently
but the desire to ignore what happened
and not improve the policy is is
um
it is only consistent at the the
absolute least pernicious explanation is
total indifference to the well-being of
service members and the Readiness of our
military force well to your point about
that that's the least bad it could be to
your point about the military getting
left behind I think you can maybe stir
up a little bit of passion for those
that are listening to this and I thank
you for taking the time to listen is
that
um you know
it's not just the simple fact that that
service members are being coerced into
taking this vaccine it's it's what's
happening with the coercion you know
from my personal experience I you know I
I literally spent my entire life trying
to be a fighter pilot I remember
distinctly thinking that my eighth grade
science fair project somehow mattered
for me getting into the Air Force
Academy
um and it's been my passion and so I
love flying I absolutely adore flying I
think it's the most fun job in the world
it's an absolute blast and so you know
to be grounded now for over a year and
watch my peers and my friends you know
put on put on the G suit and the flight
suit and go fly and rage around and hear
their stories and uh it's it's it makes
it makes me a little bummed out I mean
it's it's frustrating and it's saddening
and my story isn't even close to the
worst of it I recently spoke to a
service member uh who was told
after he got a federal injunction
protecting him from discharge that he
had two options he could either get the
vaccine or the military would move him
to the middle of nowhere Alaska with his
wife and kids because he wasn't
considered Deployable and they thought
that maybe moving him to Alaska might
convince him he ended up getting the
vaccine over that just because he knew
that moving his family to the center of
Alaska it was just not something that
was even remotely sustainable and keep
in mind again that this is after he had
a federal injunction protecting him from
discharge so the coercion's not over and
in this kind of sentiment that's
directed towards these service members
who are vaccinated is exactly what's
forcing people out I mean even our own
fighter pilot Community is is
leaving because of of things like this
our fighter pilot retention in 2021 was
below 30 that means less than 30 percent
of people who finish their 10-year
contract as an aviator are staying in
the military uh we are hemorrhaging
people at a time when we are already
1650 Pilots short in the Air Force alone
and in 2017 the chief of staff of the
Air Force called a 1500 pilot shortage a
crisis so we are in a pilot crisis and
like damage and the pilot seem to be
specifically targeted in these mandates
we are in a crisis of pilots in the
military and that's a humongous
Readiness issue and it's policies like
this vaccine program where people feel
like they're alone and left behind and
isolated and attacked that's that's
making people that are even vaccinated
to go you know what I think I'm going to
leave this organization because it
doesn't seem to represent my values or
it doesn't seem to care about me
um and I would encourage the civilian
population and all the viewers to start
speaking up about that because that kind
of sentiment is exactly how our military
crumbles and in a time like today with
China and Ukraine in Russia that's
that's a dangerous precedent to set for
our military when we need every single
service member possible
yeah I mean it's it's particularly acute
with respect to Pilots for a number of
reasons I mean you know this is not my
area of expertise but I can see first of
all that the amount we invest in the
training of Pilots is disproportionate
because the job is so Technical and so
difficult the equipment we entrust to
Pilots is extremely expensive and so and
you know here's where I'm really
speculating but I would imagine that
um as difficult a job as it is to become
a fighter pilot
uh under
simulated conditions that In the Heat of
battle the quality of Pilots is certain
to be a a central question that is to
say who can keep their their cool enough
to not only fly the plane but operate
the weapons and you know put themselves
in the right spot
so
there's something shocking about
you know of you know we're not this is
not the indifference of the command to
the Infantry which would be bad enough
right these are highly trained
professionals who are being strong-armed
into taking a vaccine that frankly is
maximally dangerous in uh in a pilot who
uh can't afford to have a sudden heart
attack in the air and you know that that
data is slow to emerge but
um the let's put it this way if you pay
attention to Medical circles in which
people are seeing Adverse Events
they are not only seeing
um anomalous heart attacks in young
healthy people they are also seeing
things like
automobile accidents uh on the rise in a
spectacular way that is consistent with
the idea that people who would
ordinarily have gotten from A to B
without a problem suddenly have a severe
medical incident behind the wheel and
the car careen's off the road that's all
the worse if you know your fifteen
thousand feet in the air
um
so you know
to the extent that there is no medical
argument for vaccinating a young healthy
person with these mRNA vaccines in the
worst case
um it's even worse when that person's
job involves extreme uh pressures on
their physiology and the necessity that
they stay absolutely competent until the
plane is back on the ground am I wrong
about this to your to your body you've
got it and I'll just add to it Brett go
ahead to your point on on the data that
you mentioned and how it's there's not a
lot of data
um I independently Quantified exactly
what you're talking about in terms of of
the pilots that could we could stand to
lose from these vaccine mandates uh I
worked with 350 unvaccinated Pilots to
generate a
Grassroots if you will study on exactly
what those Pilots mean to our national
security and and in that study of 352
Pilots which is only about half of the
unvaccinated pilots that I'm aware of in
the Department of Defense they are worth
7.8 billion dollars in tax money and
that's including salary and training
costs and everything else that's only
350 and that's 7.8 billion dollars
that's a big number and the average
years of service of those Pilots is 14
years so we're not standing to lose uh
younger inexperienced Pilots like myself
we're sending to lose extremely
experienced aviators with deployments in
actual combat experience overseas and
that's not something that you can just
recruit in uh and fix the problem
immediately as a military so these are
extremely valuable people and also their
families you know there's 800 dependents
in in that in that study as well and so
you know this has largely gone ignored
by Congress which I think is unfortunate
and I hope that many members of Congress
start to see the study that we release
because although it's not an official
study and to some degree some of those
numbers are our estimates they're
conservative estimates at the very least
and you know 14 years of service is
certainly something that's not an
estimate that's real hard data and so
with that on top of the injuries I also
helped to generate a congressional
injury report that that talks about and
has Medical Data from service members
who have been injured by the vaccine and
some of those injuries include a fighter
pilot who got pericarditis has been
grounded for seven months there was one
enlisted service member that had four
strokes after getting the vaccine
uh and so these are these are serious
injuries and Florida just recently a few
days ago released a study where they
said that they're no longer recommending
the coveted vaccine any version of the
coveted vaccine for their mRNA vaccines
at the very least for people in the 18
to 39 male age group and that's based
off of a self-controlled case study that
they did on their own data and so uh you
know it's starting to come out at least
in Florida and other locations across
the world that they're not recommending
this vaccine to people so I I can't see
how in light of that information that we
could be recommending that when we know
for a fact that this vaccine is maiming
and injuring our most competent and
qualified military members
maiming and injuring people who are
perfectly capable of fending on I mean I
believe covet is a serious disease let's
be clear about that but young people who
are healthy and the military is
disproportionately composed of such
people are perfectly capable of fending
off covid naturally it is their best
option and these so-called vaccines have
such a powerful risk profile that it
just there is no medical argument for
this right
um and you know I think you've done a
good job of exploring all of the various
ways that this
impinges on our our Readiness you know
there's the financial investment there's
the the risk to Pilots you point out uh
something I had missed which is that
you're losing the experienced pilots who
are obviously uh essential to are being
able to to fight in the air right this
really it couldn't be more foolish
English
[Music]